you burned your foot on a foreman grill
i enjoy having breakfast in bed i like
waking up to the smell of bacon sue me
and since i don't have a butler i have
to do it myself
so
most nights before i go to bed i will
lay six strips of bacon out on my george
foreman grill
then i go to sleep
when i wake up i plug in the grill i go
back to sleep again
then i wake up to the smell of crackling
bacon
it is delicious it's good for me it's a
perfect way to start the day
today i got up i stepped onto the grill
and i clamped down on my foot that's it
i don't see what's so hard to believe
about that
i was getting kind of sick of listening
to tom and and talk about their
relationship but
then i remembered that alcohol existed
thank you alcohol
[Laughter]
yes i have a wig for every single person
in the office
you never know when you're gonna need to
bear a passing resemblance to someone
i just want it to stop
april is the best but she's 20. when
april was born i was already in third
grade which means if we were friends
back then i'd have been hanging out with
a baby
i don't know anything about infant care
my god i could have killed her
i remember i blogged the whole thing
www.creedthoughts.gov dot www backslash
creed thoughts
check it out
last year creed asked me how to set up a
blog
wanting to protect the world
from being exposed to creed's brain
i open up a word document on his
computer and put an address at the top
i've read some of it
even for the internet it's
shocking
you getting weird already nope i'm good
pawnee's police chief is retiring and
i'm trying to get his endorsement before
he goes i'm really nervous because i
need this for my campaign
and ben is really nervous because he is
afraid of cops i'm not afraid of cops i
have no reason to be i never break any
laws ever
because i'm deathly afraid of cops
what is my perfect crime
i break into tiffany's in midnight
do i go for the vault no i go for the
chandelier it's priceless
as i'm taking it down a woman catches me
she tells me to stop it's her father's
business she's tiffany i say no we make
love all night in the morning the cops
come and i escape in one of their
uniforms i tell her to meet me in mexico
but i go to canada i don't trust her
besides i like the cold
30 years later i get a postcard i have a
son and he's the chief of police this is
where the story gets interesting i tell
tiffany to meet me in paris by the
trocadero
she's been waiting for me all these
years she's never taken another lover i
don't care i don't show up i go to
berlin that's where i stash the
chandelier
just a second
[Applause]
oh my god i'm sorry everybody what were
we talking about recycling dentist
pulled the tooth out yesterday
but it's always a good idea to
demonstrate to your co-workers that you
are capable of withstanding a tremendous
amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see tom faint
[Laughter]
guess what i have flaws what are they
oh i don't know i sing in the shower
sometimes i spend too much time
volunteering
occasionally i'll hit somebody with my
car
so sue me
no don't
sue me that's the opposite of the point
that i'm trying to make
that's gross i love it
we are throwing a halloween party at our
house it's gonna be the greatest thing
ever
someone will die of fun and of murder
there's gonna be beer pumpkins bloody
goblins fake ones it's gonna be awesome
we have decorations dead people that we
just murdered not murdered but pictures
of dead people from tv or movies
mutilated bodies fake ones candy dancing
tequila all kinds of food and snacks
blood orphans no blood orphans
i
i don't know what that is wait wait
actually that's a really good idea kelly
what did i say i talk a lot so i've
learned to just tune myself out
you are
wildly insanely depressed
depressed i'm the furthest thing from
depressed i mean look at what i've
accomplished do you see him do you think
a depressed person could make this
no
i told dwight that there is honor and
losing
which as we all know is completely
ridiculous but
there is however honor in making a loser
feel better which is what i just did for
dwight
would i rather be feared or loved
um easy both
i want people to be afraid of how much
they love me
and i think i proved that today at the
dojo
tom and april were excellent witnesses
in my defense
unfortunately every single word out of
their mouths was a lie there's only one
thing i hate more than lying
skim milk which is water that's lying
about being milk
since andy promoted me to assistant
regional manager i've been trying to
step my game up you know be more
productive
in fact you know what let's knock out a
few more of these sound bites while
we're here
whoa
that person has really gotten him or
herself into quite a predicament
ron you have to help me chris is making
me do some stupid management training
leadership course can you get me out of
it
yes
normally if given a choice between doing
something and nothing i choose to do
nothing but i will do something if it
helps someone else do nothing i'd work
all night if it meant nothing got done
yes
it is true i michael scott am signing up
with an online dating service thousands
of people have done it and i am going to
do it i need a username
and i have a great one
little kid lover that way people will
know exactly where my priorities are at
if you see andy will you not tell him
i'm here
okay because of what happened i don't
want him to think stop
don't want to know
the less i know about other people's
affairs the happier i am i'm not
interested in caring about people
i once worked with a guy for three years
and never learned his name
best friend i ever had
we still never talk sometimes
i haven't heard anything
but i bet jim got the job
i mean why wouldn't he he's totally
qualified and smart
everyone loves him
and
if he never comes back again
that's okay
we're friends
and i'm sure we'll stay friends
we just we never got the timing right
you know
i shot him down and then he did the same
to me and
but you know what it's okay
i'm totally fine everything is gonna be
totally fine
sorry
um
are you free for dinner tonight
yes
all right
then it's a date
sorry what was the question
you